[Music]
when one thinks about deep hole one
thinks about first avoiding the
superficial hopes like I hope that my
Domino's pizza will arrive on time or
even the ambitious hoax I hope that my
career is successful right
these things are poor tend to a future
realizable desire and they situate that
desire as probable when we think about
deep hope we're thinking about something
that's not linked to a desire to the
future to an ambition or to probability
we're thinking about a relationship to
the present and a particular kind of
discipline as one faces the present
because when one faces the present one
realizes things like life is short even
though I'd like to live long I have no
idea whether or not I will my friends my
animals are all in very contingent
relationships to much to life itself and
to me and that we walk not on concrete
but in quicksand so when you face those
real facts about what life is and you
say how do I relate to these facts the
answer I think that comes out of the
work I study is that one faces these
facts with a deep hope that's not an
aspiration it's not a probability it's
not a future orientation it's a
groundedness in the present facts of
existence unfortunately our culture has
emphasized the trivial hopes because
those are hopes that link to markets and
to achievements are always how to market
linked because markets are about growth
they're about ambition they're about
accomplishment they're about expansion
so therefore our culture really
generates a propensity to trivial and
superficial hopes right it counters and
has made a deep hope
kind of we're famished when it comes to
deep hope there's a sort of anorexia
when it comes to deep hope right we sort
of massaged and accentuated in this idea
of ourselves as consumers as
participants in the market that
venerates instant gratification and the
satisfaction of our desires in immediate
kinds of ways to generate the deep hope
the kind of hope that I think comes out
of this traditions I study one has to
really slow down and face a different
set of facts and those facts are about
the fundamentals of the experience of
life that is to say life is tragic
ones promises will never be completely
fulfilled and one's desires can never
altom utley be met that is just what
life is so how do we cultivate a deep
hope in the face of a culture which
wants to accentuate right instant
gratification and over stimulation well
I say it requires us to take some steps
back to step out of the market culture
to step away from kind of the interests
of global capital which are about
accomplishment achievement expansion and
growth and to do more work around a
sense of quietude do more interior work
and do more work in communities that
affirm togetherness and a collective
sense of what can go on outside of
markets so things like gentleness and
compassion
you know there's marvelous work that's
being done in schools and community
centers and in art workshops artists
workshops where people come together and
engage in they don't talk about hope
they just sort of quietly face the
present with a sense of being there
right and deep hope comes from
a rich engagement in those kinds of
rooted tasks that kind of groundedness
that we get from community and
collectives and relationships that have
little to do with market values but are
more about a more organic connectedness
and fundamental linkages with the true
facts of life
and one another
[Music]